Okay so you just got back from Iceland? Where
you saw some geysers. So I am going to tell you
about a sequence that has a lot of geysers in it,
it's called the Yellowstone permutation. Why it's
called a permutation will emerge in a minute. And
in this one you're actually told the first three
terms and then the rules take over. Rules are
very simple: no term is repeated; always pick
the smallest legal number; the next rule says
that the gcd - that the greatest common divisor
of the term you're putting down there then and the
previous term has to be 1. In other words, the new
number has to be relatively prime to the previous
term. But it must have a common factor with the
term two back. Let's do it. So we're told it
begins 1, 2, 3 - now what can we put down for the
fourth term? The rule says it has to be relatively
prime to 3. Okay, so it can't be divisible by 3
but it must have a common factor with 2.
Well how about 4? 4 is the smallest thing
it could be because we have to always pick the
smallest number. So we've got 1, 2 and 3 - the
smallest number we could hope to use is 4, and
4 works. Now we're missing 5, but we can't put
a 5 here because 5- even though it's relatively
prime to 4 doesn't have a common factor with 3.
So we can't put a 5; we need a multiple of 3 in
fact to have a common factor with 3. So 6 would
work, except 6 and 4 have a common factor of 2,
so we can't put a 6. So 7, 8, 9 - 9 works. 9 and
6 have a common factor of 3 and 9 and 4 are
relatively prime and no smaller number works,
so the fifth term is 9. Okay, now what?
We have to have a common factor with 4.
So 6 is missing, but we can't use 6 because of the
9. 9 and 6 have a common factor. So the next even
number after 6 is 8, and 8 works. And then we keep
going like that forever. What comes after 8? It's
got to have a common factor with 9. So a multiple
of 3- and it can't be 6 because of the 8 - so 3,
6, 9. It can't be a 12 because they have-
12 and 8 have a factor, but 15 works. Okay,
and what comes next? We need an even number after
the 8, and we don't have 6 yet but we can't use
6 because 6 and 15 have a common factor. 2, 4, 6,
8 - 8 we have. We can't use 10 because of the 15,
um we can't use 12 because of the 15 - 12 and
15 are both divisible by 3 - so it can't be 12.
Could it be 14? Yes it could, so it's a 14 and so
on. And it goes like that and- (Brady: It's cool)
- Yeah yeah. But the interesting thing is that
every so often we get a big number. Let me see if
we can get to a big number. Here is the next few
terms: finally we've got- we get the 5 that we've
been waiting for, that was the smallest missing
number so I'm glad we got that. And then we can
actually fill in the 6, and then we get 25 and
12 and 35. And 16 and 7 and so on. And you notice
all of a sudden, here, we get a number which is
three times as big as n. So it erupted upwards.
And if you look at the terms between 100 and
200 you can see that every so often there's a
geyser that erupts, just as the 35 jumped up. And
when that happens actually, they arise because we
had a prime. So this jump here is we hit the
prime 61, and then we got twice 61, and then
we got 7 times 61, that was the next term. So it
erupted. So that's what the sequence looks like.
Now in all of these sequences when you have
a rule that says there are no repeated terms,
one of the first things you want to know
is, does every number appear eventually?
And this- in this particular case
it's not obvious but it's true;
and I would like to prove it because-
(Can I ask you one more question first?
Is- are the geysers like Old Faithful? Do we
know how) (regularly they're going to go off
or are they are they scattered intermittently
like the primes? Are) (they unpredictable?)
- No they're they're predictable in the
same sense the primes are predictable.
(So not predictable then?)
- Not predictable. And yet, in a way, predictable.
Rather like the primes popping up in the string of
real numbers. - (Do they- does every prime number
cause a geyser) (or just selected ones?)
- Yes, all primes cause geysers. (Okay,
cool. What were you going to prove for us?)
- Well I'm going to prove that every
number appears. And it's- I like this proof a
lot because it's slightly clever, it's not all
due to me, it's a- this was a collaborative work.
It was uh- we ended up writing a six author paper
about this. But the proof is really lovely and
slick and what I like about it it doesn't use any
high-powered mathematics, it's just- you could
do it in your head, you could do it with your
eyes closed. There's no need to do any integration
and so on, no differentiation, no measure theory,
no probability theory. It just works. So the proof
that every number appears. That's why it's called
a permutation, because when I've convinced you
of the proof you will know that this sequence of
numbers is the same as the sequence above it,
it's the sequence of integers but rearranged,
every number appears. Okay, 1: step number 1 is-
first of all the sequence is infinite. Because you
might think after a while we run out of numbers,
but in fact there's always a candidate, we could
pick some giant prime that hasn't appeared yet-
call it q - and take 15 times q. That's definitely
going to be relatively prime to the previous
term, and certainly it has a common factor
with the two back. So there's always a candidate,
so the sequence is infinite. Now the next thing I
need is that some numbers might be missing and
some numbers will be present, and right now we
don't know. So let me define- this this is really
a subtle point but it's very a very key step. I
want to know when does a number appear? When does
8 appear? Well it appears as a sixth term. So let
me define W for when, W of m is when m appears.
W of 8 is 6, W of 15 is 7 and so on. But suppose
101 is missing; then we define W of m to be -1
if m is missing. And I want to define L of m
to be the max, the maximum, of W of 1 up to W of
m. The point is that by the time we've gone out to
W of m, every number that appears in the sequence
has appeared. This is the maximum you have to go
out to find m. You might- m might not be there
but if it is- if it is- so we take the maximum
of W for all the numbers up to m, that's- L stands
for last. L is the last chance, L of m is the last
chance you have to see an m. Once you've gone
out before beyond L of m you're in the outback,
there are no more L of m's. So for n bigger than
L of m, a of n is bigger than m. Somebody knows,
so that's how far we have to go out there. Now we
can actually do some reasoning. I claim there are
infinitely many primes that divide the terms
of the sequence. Proof: suppose not. Suppose
prime p on, all primes are missing. And then from
then on all the terms are products of primes less
than P. So I want to look at L of p squared okay?
I'm going to go out a long way in the sequence;
beyond that point we know every number is at least
p squared. So a of n is bigger than p squared;
we don't know what it is but we know it's pretty
big. And this argument about it being pretty big
is the key step, that's that's the key step number
2 that it says the sequence keeps growing. So go
out beyond the last prime less than p squared and
look at what we have. So we get a term a of n,
and we know it's bigger than p squared. We
we don't know what the number before it is
or the number two back but we know there was a
term before it that had a common factor with it
as by the definition of the sequence. And so that-
the linking term, the gcd, is a prime less than p
because from now on there are no other
primes. So the gcd here is say equal to q,
say, and we know q is less than p because all
the terms in the sequence from then on a product
so primes less than p. So that means that qp is
less than p squared - q is less than p, q times
p is less than p squared. But then because this q
is less than p we could have used q times p here
instead of p squared. And this is
a contradiction to the fact that we
always take the smallest candidate. So by
assuming that there was some limit to the
primes that appear we get a contradiction;
therefore there are infinitely many primes.
Alright,
Brady, now let me move on to the next
step. Now we know there are infinitely
many primes in the sequence, all right, I
can now prove that every prime divides some
term. Let's say 17 never divides any term;
then I say 19 can't divide any term either,
because the first time you saw a term that was
divisible by 19 you could have used 17 instead.
17 didn't appear - if 17 didn't doesn't appear you
can't have a 19 because whenever you got to a term
that had a 19 in it, you could have used the 17
instead. If 17 doesn't appear, 19 doesn't appear,
23, 101 - none of the primes bigger than 17
appear. So that means the only primes in it are 2,
3, 5, 7, 11, 13 and 17. But we know there
are infinitely many primes in the sequence,
that was step 3, so we have a contradiction.
Okay so every prime divides some term.
- (I just want to remind you, you said you could
do this with your eyes closed.) Yeah I can, I can,
I can easily do it with my eyes closed -
it's easier with my eyes closed, really.
Because I can then um correct myself without
making a fuss about it. All right, 5.
Yes. Any prime p divides infinitely many terms.
Step 4 said every prime divides some term,
so we know that 17 appears at least once. Step
5 says each prime appears infinitely many times,
and the proof is actually rather tricky; but what
you do is you say, suppose not. Here are the terms
that are divisible by p, there are only finitely
many of them, that's what we're trying to prove
can't happen. Suppose it's true; pick a power of
p which is bigger than all of them, I will prove
that's in the sequence, because pick a prime -
we know there are infinitely many primes - pick
a prime q bigger than p times 10 to the 6.
We know that q appears in the sequence. There
will come a time when q will be in the sequence;
every prime is going to appear eventually. Well
when it appears we could have used p to the
million instead, so that's a contradiction.
Therefore every poem divides infinitely
many terms. We have two steps to go:
every prime appears naked, i.e a of n then equals
p not multiplied by anything for some n. We say
suppose it's not true and find a giant. We know
there are infinitely many multiples of p, so pick
a huge multiple of p. So let's call it H times p
- huge multiple of p. Suppose find a of k equal
to a huge multiple of p, then a of k plus 2 is
going to be p. Once we've got a huge multiple of p
there's nothing to stop us taking p itself here.
It's the same argument and it's very simple.
So, okay, we're ready for the last step.
Every number appears in the sequence. So take-
suppose k is missing, smallest missing number,
and we know k isn't a prime because we know every
prime appears. So let p be a prime dividing k - a
prime factor of k - and go out a long way,
same argument, go out a long way until we get
H times a huge multiple of p. We know we can
do that by going out far enough. So what's to
stop us putting a k here two steps along? The
only thing could stop us if this term here
had a common factor with k itself. So we're okay,
we're safe, unless this also has a common factor
with k. But then why couldn't we put a k another
step on? Because this has a common factor with k,
so the only thing that could stop us is that this
term had a common factor with k. If we're going to
block- once we get to a huge multiple of p, every
term after it has to have a common factor with k.
And if it- as soon as it stops having a common
factor with k then the next term we can put k.
So we get- to block k, every term after this has to
have a common factor with k; but that's impossible
because we know if we go out far enough we're
going to come to some primes, naked primes. There
are infinitely many naked primes so there's
going to be a humongous prime sitting here
which is not- does not have a common factor with
k. So because of step 6 that can't happen.
Q.E.D, end of proof. So every number appears, that's
why it's called the Yellowstone permutation.
This is a graph of the sequence, and I want to put
in just as a reference this is the line y equals
x. This is not part of the sequence it's just a
marker. And I put down a dot for every term, and
the dots fall on lines, and what happens is that
all the primes appear very close to the line
of slope 1/2. But most of the numbers, the
non-primes, lie close to the diagonal line. Most
of the time, the nth term is about n. The primes
are exceptions and certain odd multiples of the
primes are exceptions. Some numbers that are three
times a prime appear on a different line
- (Geysers?)
Yes exactly, the geysers. There are three times p-
three times prime geysers, there are five times
geysers - sorry did I say gee-zer? We used to-
- (You cansay gee-zer or guy-zer, people- people use both.)
Oh good, all right yeah. Because we used to have a
hot water tank when we lived in the Isle of Wight
that was called a geyser; but in this country the
people say guy-ser, so I will try to say guy-ser. As
distinguished from Giza - because Giza will appear
in a different video, an old Giza. Okay, so the the
graph of the sequence: the primes are special and
they appear on a line of slope 1/2. Almost all
the other numbers appear either on a line just
above the diagonal, or on the line just below
the diagonal, very close. If you want to know to be
precise about it, there's a line whose equation is
roughly x times 1 - 1 over 2 log x. It's almost
the diagonal y equals x but there's a slight
droopiness to it. All the even numbers appear
on this line and all the odd composite numbers,
almost all, appear on a line just above it which is
y equals roughly x times 1 + 1 over log x - there's no 2
in it this time - plus ..., roughly
speaking. And then there are the geysers; and the
geysers- some of the numbers that are three times
primes appear on this line, which is slope 3/2.
Some of the numbers that are five times primes
appear on this line, which has slope 5/2.
Numbers seven times the prime and the slope is
7/2 and then 11/2 and so on. They're
the geysers.
- (How big can the geysers be? Can they-)
- Arbitrarily high, yes. They come- they become more
and more rare but you- if you go out far enough you
will see a very large geyser. This is a description
of what we see when we look at the sequence. We
don't actually have a proof that this is correct,
but we do have a theory that explains everything.
And I would just like to end up by showing you
this theory. The theory is actually wonderful. If
you study the sequence, you find that most of the
time the numbers go even, odd, even, odd, even, odd and
so on; they alternate in parity. The first 212 steps
are a little special, but from step 213 on we get
a group of five terms. At 213 we get a disruption;
twice 101, 101 as you know is a- is a prime. We get
uh 275 which is some random odd number, then we get
the prime itself, 101, then we get some random
even number which is- turns out to be 198, and
then we get at 505 which is 5 times 101. It's
five times this prime and it's the the geyser.
So this is the group of five terms that disrupted
the progression of even and odd. And using that
we're able to say, well the even numbers appear on
the line y is x times 1 minus 1 over twice log x.
Look, I don't think anyone's ever going to
reach Neil Sloane's level of sequence expertise,
but if you want to lift your game on any area of
mathematics or science including sequences then
you really need to check out today's episode
sponsor, Brilliant. Their online lessons and
courses are elegantly and lovingly designed; you
aren't just a spectator. There are quizzes and
questions and interactive elements like this. Get
smarter, get thinking, train your brain. Brilliant
makes learning so much fun you're gonna wish you
started this years ago. And get 20% off Brilliant's
premium subscription at brilliant.org/numberphile
There it is on the screen, and I'll put
a link in the video description too. Check
it out now, your brain will thank you later.